tras su tercera reunión para tratar de
alzar el límite de la deuda en Estados
Unidos Kevin mccarthy salió a atender
los medios de comunicación tras reunirse
con biden en el salón oval dijo que el
tono de esta reunión había sido muy
positivo positividad es como resumiría
esta reunión de la presidente de la
cámara de representantes el republicano
Kevin mccarthy diciendo que él cree que
aunque la fecha límite para estar el
límite de la deuda sea el primero de
junio y se tenga que aprobar en el
congreso todavía hay tiempo para
lograrlo descartó una salida de corto
tiempo es decir alzar marginalmente el
límite de la deuda para ganar tiempo en
una negociación definitiva también
descartó el tema del recorte de defensa
para poder llegar a un acuerdo el
defensa no se va a cortar los gastos
dijo él el presidente de la cámara de
representantes también en lo que tiene
que ver con los gastos siguió
insistiendo que la administración de
Alguien ha gastado cifras millonarias
desde que llegó a la casa blanca y que
precisamente eso es lo que quiere cortar
lo republicanos el chorro en el gasto
Público de la administración de biden
volvió a Resaltar que no está de acuerdo
en aumentarle los impuestos a las
personas que ganen más de 400.000
dólares al año como lo ha venido
diciendo el presidente Joe biden y que
se necesitan más gastos para que la
economía de Estados Unidos esté más
sólida eso es lo que Argumenta el
republicano Kevin mccarthy para poder
llegar a un acuerdo sin embargo pues ya
hemos conocido que de parte de la
administración de biden lo que ellos
quieren es levantar este límite de la
deuda después de la pandemia teniendo en
cuenta la cantidad de gastos que tuvo
que incurrir el gobierno Y pues seguir
financiando el tema de la deuda
estudiantil y la producción la
generación de energía verde unos temas
que no quieren seguir financiando los
republicanos